uh just bringing some breaking news  tracy connolly the mother of baby p the  the little boy who died after months of  abuse is to be released from prison this  is after the parole board today rejected  a government challenge  against its ruling baby p as i said died  after months of abuse connolly was  jaired at the old bailey back in 2009  for causing or allowing the death of her  17 month old son peter at their home in  tottenham north london in  2007 it was her fourth parole board  hearing  they deemed her suitable for release the  government  challenged that decision but it has been  overruled by the parole board today so  tracy connolly the mother of baby p is  to be released from prison